voici l'image que les usagers espérer
voir depuis deux semaines la signature
du protocole d'accord à la cft vous en
présence de la direction du travail et
du maire de fort de france
syndicats et direction ont donc mis fin
à une grève de deux semaines une grève
ou plutôt un droit de retrait car pour
sortir du conflit la direction a
finalement accepté cette dénomination
qui permet aux employés de ne pas perdre
leurs salaires nous acceptons de
considérer qu'il était on était dans un
droit de retrait et bien que nous
appliquions les règles en la matière
c'est à dire pas de retenues sur salaire
pour les deux semaines de grève
oui dans la mesure où bon nous avons
voulu privilégier le
la reprise qu'est ce qui les empêche de
recommencer la semaine prochaine la
semaine d'après parce que c'est de plus
en plus souvent maintenant sur le réseau
alors ceci est fait
moyennant le principe que les uns et les
autres aient bien compris que désormais
ce genre de chose n'était plus possible
plus de droit de retrait à l'avenir côté
syndicats on n'a apparemment pas entendu
la même chose à 90 tout temps où on la
doit on aller bouffer red alert la
bâtisse y en a d'autres qui ne les paie
donc on n'a pas de social à ce niveau là
vous réalisez que au niveau des usagers
il ya un sentiment d'agacement et la
sensation que vous faites grêve tout le
temps en fait oui on peut comprendre ça
on est conscient c'est qu'effectivement
on a découvert à répétition j'ai pas de
watts à répétition mais il faut qu'on
bannisse ce criminel doit nous vous
devez conducteurs ont fait c'est surtout
sur la sécurité
la question risque en tout cas de se
reposer bien vite le protocole d'accord
prévoit un calendrier de réparation des
bus défectueux mais pas la réintégration
de la salariée licenciée à l'origine du
mouvement
ceci devrait être traitée dans le cadre
d'un autre préavis de grève déposé
prochainement par le syndicat sud qui
n'a pas souhaité nous répondre
se pose aussi la question du sous
traitant écartés du marché est venu
réclamer le paiement d'une facture nous
rapprocher du syndicat parce que ils
attendaient pour savoir comment sur l'
os et puis nous allons prendre des
décisions cela suite à mener mais il est
évident que le rize autre a perdu à
nouveau y viennent de signer de terminer
une grève et vous êtes en train de dire
aux usagers qui ont déjà souffert
pendant deux semaines que vous allez
embrayé sur l'agglo grève n'est pas
finie et là ils ont déposé une malette
c'est pas fini donc aujourd'hui
ça permet à la population de savoir
qu'il y a quand même des solutions qui
qui ont été prises et que les syndicats
sont d'accord pour reprendre le travail
sur le réseau les semaines à venir
pourrait apporter d'autres
rebondissements
pour l'heure en tout cas la reprise du
service est bel et bien annoncé par la
cft ou progressive à partir de demain